Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Super Mario Maker.
Now we're back in the middle of the expert levels
And I know it's gonna get a lot harder.
I know that I'm going to not have a good time with this--actually, I'm gonna have a wonderful time with this.
I'm not worried about having fun. What I am worried about is losing my goddamn mind
before I get to the end
and hopefully rescue Princess Peach
because I got 64 lives left, and...oh hi...
OOHHH, GAH-I DIDN'T KNOW, I wasn't ready!
I was too distracted by the fact that there was a giant Bowser standing in the middle of nothingness...
Alright, I just gotta run...
hab~!
Thank you.
Ooh why..? Why would you do this?
I'm not good about being careful
Heh! Oh-hohohoho
Am I just...
Oh no.
Let me, let me put this a little-
Can I? Yeah!
I probably didn't put that WHERE I NEEDED TO... NYE-HEH!
Okay... OH, you have got to be yanking on some...
FUCK.
Oh, this is going to be a bi-hi-hi-hi-hiiitch (laugh)
How is this just in the expert levels?
This better be the only challenging part about it.
It better get real easy, real soon.
Heh! Oh, hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo
Okay well, that's... not where I...
HEH! (with jump)
Huh-uh-uh-huh
Oh man.
oh.
Ha! Oh.
Well, AHH!
I wasn't even looking out for that one!
I was trying to go up on the other ones.
Oh, this is going to be a nightmare...
of epic proportions.
As is my life in Mario Maker! This is what I have been subjected to.
This is what you guys asked for!
You thought it was too easy, on the other levels I was getting away with,
And I almost thought that I got away with them.
If it wasn't for those darn, meddling kids.
Ok.
OHHH NOO!
I thought I was fast, but it turns out I'm dead.
Ok. I'm pretty sure if I just get past that part--that's going to be, like, the chokepoint of all of this.
Because the rest of this...is just about being slow and cautious.
And "slow and cautious" isn't exactly in my job description, but...
AWH! Why didn't you jump off of that?
I'm not the best at the wall jump.
Oh, this is where it all gets lost. This is where it *all* gets lost.
Level ten; I've still got six more to go after this.
Getting pretty confident about that part, I'm going to get cocky soon.
Ahhhh! Ok.
Woah!
Just-- JOh!-- That's, uh, that's not good.
Hah, ah, AH! Why?! Why wouldn't you jump?! I pushed the button!
Ah man, do I not need to hold down 'Y'?
Could I-Could I just jump without the 'Y' button?
Because, the 'Y' button's the 'run' button. The 'run faster' button,
and I don't think I need it when I'm going up there but,
I-oh. Oookay
Like I said, I was gonna get rushing, and then I was gonna get cautious.
And my hair's still wet 'cuz I just popped out of the shower.
But you guys don't care about that,
that has nothing to do with how I'm doing in Mario Maker
GODDAMIT! Stop rushing!
FUDGESICLES!
WHY?
WHYYYYYY?
Easy easy
Why didn't you jump-- ugh...
No?
F-- jump on the last one, dammit
AH! WHAT THE FUCK!
JUST-- GODDAMMIT
Ugh...
Just--just WHY WOULDN'T IT JUMP ON THE LAST ONE?
Yea, got that on lock, okay
So just run forward, twirl once
Yeaaaaaaaaaaaa, there we go! There we go!
Yes PLEASE be the end!
Is it the-- OHHH
I feel like that's a trick!
I can get out of there right? Yea. I can-- I can get out of this.
AW NO. NAW HAW. NO HO HO HO HO.
GODDAMMIT.
IT WAS A TRI--HIHIHICK
OHHHHHHHHHHHH NO HO HO HO
SON OF A-- BIIIIIIIIIIII--
Okay now, don't go by the super distracting--
Yaaaaaaaaay and whoa hello.
Alright so what do we got now?
Hopefully it's easy-street from now on
(Nope, it isn't :P)
*interested noise* Hello~
Okay. Is this a choice?
If you frick me over with a bad choice here--
Where am I?
YOU SON OF A BITCH
ITS A RANDOM CHOICE?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
ARE YOU FRICKIN YANKING MY DONG?
Ohhhh my GOD!
You are a giant, GIANT hole in the ground FILLED with dicks
I don't even know what-- what circumstances that would be
but that's what you are, developer of this level--
FUCK. God stupid mistakes.
Stupid, stupid, stupid.
(Wait for it...)
NO I-- NAW COME ON YOU CAN'T FUCK ME OVER LIKE THAT
AAAAAHHHHHH. THIS IS SUCH BULLSHIT.
Goddammit, why did I have to get this level? Why?
Oh, why did I have to get this level? Why is this my RANDOMLY assigned level? Why?
No! Agh shit.
Okay.
So what is with this ledge here?
Am I just supposed to--
Is it- Is it like all of them are a trick?
Cause I would believe THAT.
AH HA. Maybe th-- oh...
Well that doesn't look good.
Alright let's see what happens.
HUP
Ook--gaah.
Goddammit.
You sack of crap.
Hup. AAAAHHHH FU HUHUHUHUCK
All the way there.
All the way there and I'm cut off by THAT dickitry.
What a piece of shit.
No! No! No! No!
Oh my god! Oh my god! Oh my god! Oh wow!
(Sick skills mate)
~What The Fuuuck Is Going On~
ohhhh
FUCK YOUUUUU
Ha okay.
Just gotta get past this part.
(Sorry Mark...)
No! YOU CAN GO TOO HIGH?
Twenty-eight...
Twenty-eight!
Twenty-eight!! Are you kidding me?!
It's like he saves the douchiest--
NOOO*voice crack*OOOO! NOHOHOHO
AGHHHHHHHHHHH
*Angry exhale*
NOohohohoho....hohohoho
Thank you for not panicking, me.
You're welcome me! :)
Why don't you just do it right the next time? >:(
Oh~ No, I won't. Don't worry about that. o3o
*exhale*
Ugh...
No! Oh man!
Walking into it?!
Why are there no deaths over there?
Wai-- Why are there no deaths over there?
That's a good question.
Why are there no "x" arrows over there?
Tha-- It seems to me like that's where ALL of the arrows would be.
Or ALL of the marks would be.
All the marks--
*laughs at own unintentional pun* all of MY deaths over there, yea that's true.
Okay, jus--just because this is rigoddamndiculous
I--I wanna see where these other pipes lead
if there just so happens to be something here or if it's just nothing.
I--I--It's--It's just nothing. It's--It's *stutters*
Wow...holy crap...
Twenty...I have twenty lives left.
I have TWENTY LIVES LEFT.
TWENTY
You know it's--it's not like I expected this to be EASY.
I didn't. I'm--I'm no foo--No! No! No!
WHY?
GAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAD
I'm sorry everybody. I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
(It's okay Markimoo)
I'm so--rihihihihihi.
I just feel such--I feel like such a disappointment to everybody out there.
I feel like I'm just failing you all.
Individually, and you're all just like:
You're not mad at me, you're just -you're just disappointed and it's like
"Well ya know we HAD high hope for you Mark, you went into this--
you were more than halfway done with these and you had
Ya know
OVER half the lives you required so
we didn't see how this could go wrong."
Little did you know.
Little ol' Markimoo was ready to shit out another turd in terms o' gameplay.
(shit)
Argh...
I didn't even get to the spin!
I didn't even get the FIRST jump right!
OHHHHHHHHH...
OHHHH...
OHHHHO NO!
OH NO NO NO NO NO NO NO NO
NOOOOOOOOOOO
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
*rage intensifies*
YOU AAAAAAAASSHOOOOOOOLE
(Oh boy)
(Wait for it...)
That is douchiness BEYOND douchiness!
I beat this--
DOOOOOON'T
FUUUUCKIN' NO.
I'M NOT-- NO NO.
I BEAT this shit, this is FUCKING bullshit!
I'm down to TWELVE lives!
GAWDDAMMIT WHYYYYYYYYY?
AGHHHHHHHHHHHHH
FUCKING FUUUUCK
Who put a super expert level-- what are you?!
Oh goddammit...
Ugh..
Wh--why is that not what it's supposed to be?
Goddammit...
Ohhh...
Ohhhhhhh.....
Ohhhhhhhhh...........
Great.
What is this?
What--do something!
Okay.
This is cool.
I'm happy about this.
I'm happy about this new level that I'm on.
What am I doin'?
PLEASE tell me this just rides me all the way down.
Because I don't wanna have to deal with--
Thank you!
Thank you for the look of confidence Mario.
I'm not too happy about it either...
WELL this looks fun! I really hope this just--
th--Please?
Whoa!
*deeper voice* whoa hello.
Why is this here?
Okay whatever.
So long as it's just it--this better just be
AH!
Okay... oh I know what needs to happen--
whoa what are yo--whoa what?!
Ohhh kay?!
Well he was just gonna CHARGE at me that's something Bowser's never really done before.
What a load of ass...
*inhale*
But just get me through this goddamn level so that I can get on with my goddamn life
and then go back to doin' something stupid...
Nuh--NO WHAT THE FUCK?!!!
You gotta be fucking with me.
You gotta be FUCKING kiddin' me.
Oh my gawd.
That's such a stupid thing!
Whyyy?
Kay so apparently
There is a-
powerup here--don't don't don't!
*Marki rage*
No- why is he over here? Fuck you.
Okay...just keep backin' up or somethin', I don't know what you're doin'.
Oh god, no no.
Ahhh- oh my god, how did I get out of that?
I don't even know.
Okay, I gotta get him to shoot fireballs at the other way but he's just--
He's being a ROYAL dick right now.
King Koopa the--ohhh... really...
FUCK it's even worse.
Well that sounded like something blowin' up--
NO!
(Sad train coming through)
WHAT?
Are you kidding me?!
Well I FOUND the SECRET.
Oh my god. Are you kidding me?
I don't have these lives to lose!
Fuck you. Fuuuck you. Fuck you.
Fuck you...
What an asshole...
What a goddamn asshole these developers.
What fucking assholes.
Okay. Where was that secret?
Give. Give to me, there we go. I got it now.
Well this is good...
Oh shit oh shit--no-no--well...
Well this is good enough.
You know what, I'll take it.
Wh-where is i--there it is.
Hup!
Ah shit- well lost it anyway--you know what, fuck you.
Goddamn it, are you kidding me?
N-No! God no! Don't be like this!
Just let me go by you!!!
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
AGH.
JUST LET ME GO BY!
Are you kidding me?!
Why won't he-
Ah! Okay. Fuck you!
Fuck-FUUUUUUUUUCK YOUUUUUUUUUUU!
OHHHHH SUCK DONG
(sweet release)
Oh man...
So anyway, thank y'all so much for watching Mario Maker
This episode has been--I've been wor--for forty-I never--
*trying to words*
*exhale*
I'm gonna fail the 100 Mario Challenge, I am.
There's no way.
Such. Such bullshit.
So thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always I'll see you in the next video.
Give me some words of encouragement in the comm--you better not kill me right off the bat.
You better not. You better not.
If you do I will-
*whispers* I'll strangle you by your balls. *whispers*
*regular voice* See you in the next video.
I am broken inside...
And as always, I'll see you in the next video-
Bye bye! :D